so CNN Paul Michael so obviously these
guys know what they're talking about so
CNN poll uh most Republicans care more
about picking the 2024 GOP nominee who
agrees with them on issues than one who
can beat Biden okay so this poll shows
that only 30 percent of Republicans and
republican-leaning independents believe
that the country's best days are still
ahead of it this represents a
significant shift from 2019 when 70 70
77 percent of Republicans were
optimistic when asked about the 2024 GOP
nomination 59 of Republicans prioritize
a candidate who agrees with their views
on major issues over one who has strong
chance of beating President Biden the
poll also shows that 38 of Republicans
view increasing racial ethnic and
National diversity as a threat which is
twice as high as four years ago
additionally 78 believe that society's
values on sexual orientation and gender
identity are changing for the worst and
79 think that the government is trying
to do too many things that should be
left to individuals and businesses what
do you think about this I think the
reasons people give for why they vote
the way they do or almost never the
actual reasons right no one says I voted
for the better looking person I voted
for the taller person but they're going
to have a rationalization after the fact
that like oh I like him more for the
issues or I like his career kind of like
the Kennedy thing you were talking about
right exactly so I think when people are
asked what you're looking for it's not
necessarily what they're actually going
to do in the voting booth number one
number two is uh I don't think Trump has
a very good shot uh pun intended because
as soon as they start talking about the
factory stuff especially with the base
as soon as you start talking about his
Staffing decisions uh it's going to look
pretty bad for him and I also think that
there is enough in um impetus on the
Democratic side for him to be either
kind of
um charged with some kind of crimes
because I think you think so if I'm an
attorney general and I have the
possibility of Prosecuting a former
president that's going to catapult me a
state attorney general to some national
Fame and history books so the incentives
are very much there for uh you know
Democratic party operatives to push him
as far as they can why wouldn't they no
when you say you don't think he's got a
shot
um Define that meaning he has a great
shot of winning the Republican primary I
think general election I don't think he
has to go to shot the primary how could
you possibly say that he's 60 in the
seat he's going to tell you if you don't
stop interrupting me Michael malice CPAC
is irrelevant as you know because if you
last CPAC what it was at this point in
2016 I don't think Trump's name was even
there uh or maybe he was because he just
spoke at number one number two is he's
gonna have an issue with fundraising
because now the it's he's become so
radioactive that if I'm a big
businessman and I'm giving him money
it's going to be a problem for me and my
customers because all the presses are
going to be on top of it uh there's
going to be enormous uh amount of
there's a space now if I am Facebook or
am I some or CNN or Fox for me to say no
to his ads because now it's been
established that this guy felmented
Insurrection I don't believe that's true
at all but that is the argument so it's
easy for me as a corporation who's going
to be almost always left the center to
be like oh I can't take your money
because you're not a patriot so on and
so forth so he has a lot more stacked
against him now than he did even in
2016. so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]